REPORTING ON T
POTENTIAR THE BREAKING NEWEVENI.
JA
COWHO COR
PRESIDENT INTO T FORME
PRESIDEN SCHEME.
CNN IAENIS PART OF THE TEAM THA.
SO, JAMIE TALKINTHE HIEF OF STA
HOE LEARMAFORMERENT PENCE'T ADV
ALONG WITH MEAGUESRRAV
LEARNE COMMITT
OFFICIALS, HT GHOENAERMP
AND,SON, COOPERATION NIFICANT U
YOU SAY, A FIRST W
SOY CRITICAL EVENTS.
CA 6th
HE A OVAL OFFICE
ONUA
CONVINCEENRTIFY ULRUMP TRIED T
SO, UMAL THIURO ONTHSS PENCE'SIE
COOPERATION NCE.,
FOR, SHOR
CONSIDEREDF PENCE'S MOST
S. IS HARD TO IMAGIN MARK
SHORULHECOMMITTEE S
BLES. EAD  A
PRESIDENT'S TEAM IS ALTEE, VERS.
WH KIND OF INFORMATION OR
MENTS WOULSHE?
TO JANUARY 6thLIKET HE KNO WHATD
CAPITOL ON
IT'S LIKELK SHOR
WHO WAS CHIEF OF SO PENCE --AS
MALI MK OWS IEOF TDONALD
HAPPENING?IOT WAS GOING
WH -- O
E
CONVERSATION P,
TEXTS.
THINGS THAT HAPPENED IN
REAL-TON JANUARY 6th., PERHAPHEM
THE COMMITTEE S.
WHAT WAS DONAL
Y DI'TVE
QUICKLTOACTION
>> AND WHAT E OURCES
TELLINE MOTIVATION
ND PEOPLE IN INNERCIRCLE W A
G?
I ME AND ALSO,VI THER
PRT IS EITHER KEACT?
>>HT, PEE TEN ISINREIMSELF FRO
SORT OF COME BAC T., SAY I D G
ON -- ON
YBE SEES THI
BASE. TO GETDIFFERLAE REPUBLICAN
AS FOR DON LET'S
IT.HEHATH,
D  HISTORY WITH MARK
SHORT.
HE WASY  T ARK SHORT FROM THE WE
THAT PCEIS
BIDDING, ANDN.AMIE, STAYH US.
I GTON
PO" ATE EDITOR BOB
WORD
WITH ROBERA IN NEW
"PERIL."SO, CN
DAVI.B,AMOBOUT OFR BOOK Wh
AND THE EVENTS TLE
HOW BIG A DEAL IS IT
EW
COOPERATING  COULDN'T GEBETTERS
THOF STAFFTHIS  -- AT TH SIGNIFT
TICAL ENVIRONMENT IS THE
THE CONSF CIAIN
MENT
HERECE ANDSHARE DEEP RELIGIOION.
WHEN PENCE CFI BIDEN DE T ENT T
IKYING I HAVE FOUG THEOURSE.TS P
AYS
INUS
UNHO, YOU SEE  A CRITICAL MOMEN
NGRESSMAN E'
DAYS IN THE.T -- I MJUST,  KNOHS
CE
IT'S DOCTS
>> YEAH, THERE I DOUBTAT.AND AT
GEI , WHO MORE IGOIN ABOUTPRESS
GLAD YOU RAID  , BECAUSE THIS G
PO
LY VABLATWOULD S WITHOUT THE TA
YOU MENTIONED HE WAS T
OF STAFF IN THE HOUSE RE
CONFERENCE F PINRS OF THE OBAMA
ADST
HE- VED WITH
HI 2016 MPWHEN TRUMP PUTCE ON T
, WENT INTO
THE WHITE HOAN
HIS CHIEF OF STA
THIS IS A LONGTIMEALID IDO
APPROVAL.
IT'S -- IT'S JUS
TO THINK OTHERWISE.
>> AND HAVE
THE PAST THA
ARE SOMEBETHE PENCE
IF MARK ORD  MORWI
WOULD POLY?A T
>>M RERT
ARATS OF  WEEKS AGO THAT
PENCE WORLD THHE T TO.
WHO WAS ALSO IN THFFICE
WHENMP WAS P
PENCE.THAT AANS HE COMMITTEES F
MORE AND MORE CONFIDENT THATMOR
WAS PHYSICALLYEN-VICE PREST
JANUARY 6th AS,
ARG MIKE
WHICRESIDENT DESCRIBED AS -- ASU
COMMON-SENSE REACTION
BECAE  AND
GET SHORT PRISED THMM
GEINTO WAS, O YOU THINK THAT'S F
LOOK, I WA TO DO THIS BUT U
E?
>> WELOUYOU DON'
T V YOU
OURH THE YADUTIFUL, VICE PRESI
ALWAY
AND P THAT'SREFERRING TO AROUNP
LO LAWYERS, POLITICAL
ADVISERS, PEOPLE ALWAYS SAYING
TO PENCE YOU NEE S YOUR OWN.
ESU HA.
61 YEARSI D CERTAINLY, WANTS TOD
THIS IS A -- A
E DOOR.
THF OF STAFF IS PEON O LT,ALMOS.
IT REALLY BRINGS YOUE  FACE WITL